なんでこんなの家にある？
空気砲ってあるじゃないですか
あれのレーザーポインター付きの狙いの的を定めて撃てる空気砲です。
うわすごいなでも
本気じゃん
え、これもうスタンドスタンドスタンド付いちゃってんじゃん
あ、違う　こうやって撃つのか
怖い怖い怖い
ほんとにこれ...人死なないかな
ゴリゴリのヤンキーが使う空気砲だからもう多分殺傷力はマジでヤバいと思います
僕、空気砲好きなんすよ
Amano（Amazon）で探してたら明らかに異常な値段で売ってましたこの空気砲。
*口笛*
空気砲なんてだって普通段ボールとかで作れますからね箱とかで。
もうこれやばいもん作りが。
海外製のなんかマジでやばそうな空気砲なんで
で、レーザーポインター付きでしょ？
完全に
まじでこれ強そうなんで一回組み立ててみますわ
そもそも組み立て方がわかんないもん
説明書多いそして。
え、待って　めっちゃめっちゃあるんだけど
え、待って　空気撃つだけじゃないの？
マジでマジでわかんない
これなんか難しいな
やっぱ人を殺めることのできる空気砲は違うレベルが。
まじかこれすげー難しいな
きたねぇウェディングケーキだ。
え、まだ¿もう無理だよ
これで付けちゃいます多分。
え、ちょっと待って　マジむずいマジむずいマジむずい
え、待って　ホントに難しい
痛い！無理ポ無理ポ
（”タイトル”って何だよ、タイトルって）
え、無理だよ！
おわーーーーあーーーー！！
入んない入んないホントに入んない
マジ！
（こんな時でもお菓子は）
（人の気持ちを落ち着かせるのです。）
（味わっています）
無理だもんだってこれ
待ってこれ物理的に厳しくない？マジ。
無理だもん！どう考えても付かないよこれ
ンアーーッ
今なんかイッた気がした
あーーきたーー！
あーーあーーあーー⤴
あーーもうこれ怖いよ
あとは余裕だわ多分。
めっちゃ固かったですホントに。
これ大丈夫？
どこまで本気やねん（エセ関西弁）
これでひとまず見た目は完成じゃないでしょうか
あとは電池を入れたらレーザーポインターが出ます。
うっはぁwwちょっと待って
すごいなこれ
ちょ自分に撃ってみます
え、これやばくない？
wwwww
*RIP 織田信長*
やばいやばい
そこら辺の軽い物だと多分余裕で倒せます
え、これすごいぞ
さすがに無理だ
わっもうやばいもうもう出てるもう出てるもう出てるよ
うわっこれがレーザーポインターか
うわっ怖い怖い怖い
こういう感じに敵に焦点を当てて
バァッンと撃てると。
レーザーポインター付きとかまじ目ぇぇぇぇ
レーザーポインター危ないので人の目はやめましょうね
はいというわけでレーザーポインター付き
完全にトドメを刺しに行ってる空気砲で
ちょっとたまたま来てる生意気な友達の
いやこれホント威力すごいからね
音が破裂音ですもん
あそこのガムテープ狙ってみます
レーザーポインターで狙い定めていきます
わっほら
はいというわけで完全に破格の威力を持っています
こちら早速生意気な友達をぶっ飛ばしに行こうと思います
ではいこう
友達：おいおいおいおい
はじめ：そういうのじゃないから
*空気砲をセット*（危険な香り）
友達：え、何々？！（どっきりですか？）
友達：何々？！おわああ（思ったとおりじゃん）
友達：何々？！何それ？！（もっとやって）
友達：何やってんの？！何やってんの？！（楽しい）
死ねーー
友達：何々？！
おおぉぉおおお
友達：なんだこれ？？！！！！
友達：待って、結構いたいたああ
友達：おおぉ痛い
痛い痛い痛い痛い
友達：結構痛い結構痛い
はじめ：本当に？
友　達：結構痛い
はじめ：じゃあ撃ってじゃあ
わっわっわっダメだダメだ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ（※死にません）